I think the election of Jeremy Corbyn
has brought about a moral crisis that
people on the Left who like to think of
themselves as terribly moral and
terribly correct has not yet come to
terms with other they will have to soon
and that is this here you have a
politician who goes along regimes which
we old lefties used to call from an
extreme rides ego like Iran where gays
are persecuted women in our subjugated
ethnic religious minorities are
oppressed and afraid unions are locked
up with Hamas with Hezbollah with Putin
with every variety of Holocaust denier
9/11 truther nut job and crank and this
meant to be left now this is meant to be
we meant to have a left where we all run
around screaming our heads off when
David Cameron says calm down dear but in
all of that that leader of the Labour
Party go on Iranian television not even
raise his voice in protest against the
real oppression of women in Iran this is
meant to be the left where we all shout
racism all the time that's often largely
innocent Tories and sometimes even
largely innocent kippers and yet we have
a leader of the Labour Party who
associates with the most grotesque NBC
mics this is this problem between
building and building and building for
years with the left is about to explode
and they will find that far from
electing the most principled candidate
in Jeremy Corbyn they've elected the one
who'll expose ins from those criticism
I think who knows prophecies offer fools
and and you only have to look at the
polls before the last election so my
guess is this it's going to take at
least a decade to sort this mess out and
it may take a generation the the right
has from the French Revolution onwards
the right has always been strongest we
can tell say to working-class
middle-class people the left wingers
they hate your country they hate England
they love every country but their own
and unfortunately with Jeremy Corbyn
there's enough evidence to make that
charge stick
conservative but I went vote Labour when
Jeremy Corbyn says leader or vote for
any Labour candidate who endorsed him as
my MP has and the mayoral candidate has
here in London so there you go
I'm off pi resign